what would happen if you gave up bread for 14
days let's talk about that what's in bread well
you have gluten you have refined grains sugar
starch you have sometimes even flavorings
you have conditioners for the texture of the
bread mold inhibitors phytates which actually
will block your zinc your calcium and your
iron and glyphosate which is an herbicide
so number one you would feel less bloating why
because so many people either have an allergy to
gluten or they have gluten intolerance so they're
gonna have a lot of inflammation in their gut and
that's gonna lead to bloating not to mention
the refined carbohydrates in general are going
to create bloating so you'll have less bloating
number two you'll have more zinc calcium and iron
okay three your head's gonna feel a lot better
less brain fog more mental clarity less headaches
better memory more attention less adhd that's
cool number four a better mood less irritable
because your blood sugars are going to be better
less anxiety less depression there's a connection
between what's happening in your gut or what you
just ate and what's going on up here so you're
just going to feel overall much better with your
mood number five less pain and inflammation not
only does the gluten cause inflammation but the
refined carbs and the sugar will increase your
inflammation so if you have arthritis fibromyalgia
all that's going to be much better anything itis
is going to be better number six more weight loss
less belly fat because you're going to have less
insulin number seven more energy okay number
eight less diabetic symptoms and lower a1c well
actually i like you might not have a lower a1c
because that usually takes like three months and
if you just check it after 14 days you might not
see a change but you should see better blood sugar
levels number nine decrease ldl and less oxidation
in your arteries that's cool and 10 you're gonna
have more vitamin e in your body and you're
gonna have more b vitamins why because refined
grains refined carbohydrates deplete you of
vitamin e and the vitamins what's that going
to do it's going to help you breathe better it's
going to give you more endurance with your heart
you're going to have less angina attacks your
heart's just going to work a lot better and you
also have less oxidation in the arteries which
is going to decrease the risk of getting a clot
or a clogged artery because vitamin e
is the major antioxidants to protect you
but other than these 10 things you know i
can't think of any other good things that
can happen so i don't know try it out give up
bread for 14 days and let me know what happens
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story
please share it in the link down below